welcome back the vegasville knights play  minnesota again tomorrow and  hopefully that game turns out better  than last night the knights and wild  were tied at two  they couldn't sort things out in  overtime went to a shootout where the  wilds pulled ahead for a 3-2 win  we headed our chances they had theirs um  i think when we're playing our best  we're playing five on five hockey and  we're a little stingier on giving those  rush chances so  um you know something that we can look  to  to build on and get better for next game  after the game against minnesota  tomorrow the knights hit the road for a  two game series in st  louis coming up next week they have a  busy schedule